but first it's been 20 years since the
invasion of Iraq rightly or wrongly
feuded more to call attention to the
conduct of U.S military in that war than
the WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
Wikileaks made Global headlines in 2010
by publishing leaked classified files
and evidence of war crimes fighting as
tradition to the U.S in 157 years in a
maximum security jail Assange took
refuge in the Ecuadorian Embassy he was
arrested after emerging and has now
spent four years four years in belmarsh
prison probably the toughest prison in
the country supporters say he's a free
speech Champion who's shown a light on
Military brutality critics think he's
nothing less than a terrorist who
threatened National Security
my name is John Shipton I'm Julian
assange's father
he's found that Julian Assange has been
arrested one of the most notorious and
controversial figures in custody
Assange will remain Behind Bars until
that extradition hearing which has been
set down for the end of February
[Music]
urged the Department of Justice to drop
the charges
the maximum jail sentence of 175 years
[Music]
well I'm joined Now by Julian's Father
John Shipton and his brother Gabriel
Shipton who've made that new documentary
film on their fight to secure Julian
assange's release along with security
and terrorism expert we'll get it so
welcome to all of you uh thank you very
much to the shiptons uh who are joining
me from America let me start with you
John Shipton you're Julian's dad
um it must be regardless of the debate
that we're about to have about this
incredibly tough for a father
see a son a child incarcerated for so
long without any apparent conclusion to
be legal proceedings in belmarsh which
I've been to which is one of the
toughest prisons in the country
I it appears it's very difficult and the
circumstances of Julian's declining
Health make the the matter dire and
critical
John how often do you speak to your son
uh Julian is allowed a 10-minute phone
call to me uh daily I haven't spoken
today but the day before yesterday we
had a 10-minute conversation
how would you categorize his State of
Mind
uh well it goes up and down generally
not good but as we report upon the
journey across the United States and
then the enthusiasm with which we're
greeted this is heartening for Julian
and uh lifts his spirits considerably
you know
you know John I've been a journalist for
more than three decades I've run big
newspapers in the UK I've covered this
story obviously extensively and I
watched a movie the other day again in
preparation for this interview actually
just to remind myself of the whole story
as it all played out and a large part of
me has a lot of Sympathy For What Julian
Assange did you know he exposed some
really serious things and he did it in a
Fearless way there's no question of that
but apart to be also when I was reminded
of this felt that his actions in in the
way he did it could well be categorized
as Reckless just putting everything out
there uh seemed to me something which
for example as an editor of a newspaper
we would never have been able to do
um did you when you saw what he did did
you have qualms as his father that that
particular action in just putting it all
out
was uh was something that was always
going to get him into this kind of
trouble
oh please you know first place I have to
accept your assertion and just putting
it all out which is uh if you forgive me
for saying so quite directly incorrect
the uh there were a hundred Media
Partners uh with Julian uh each of them
responsible for a particular area all of
this was covered in the hearing that the
reductions the ultimate release of all
of the cables
unredacted was done by
kryptone.org John Young site in New York
your half brother
you've made this film you guys because
you're desperate to try and get him out
I guess of prison
how is that going what reaction are you
getting particularly in America
well we're getting very emotional
reactions here in the U.S where about
halfway through a 59 event tour around
the United States
people are enraged when they realize
what's going on uh how their rights are
at stake in in Julian's persecution
people after we do showings people come
up to us and say you know thank you for
doing this thank you for standing up for
our first amendment in the United States
so it's it's really breathtaking that
audiences around the US are really
beginning to understand what's at stake
for them in this in this case their
Democratic right to know what
governments do in their name
uh back in October I interviewed John
Bolton he was a former U.S national
security advisor of course and he said
this to me
he's committed clear criminal activity
he's no more a journalist than the chair
I'm sitting on the information that he
divulged did in fact put many people in
Jeopardy it undercut the ability of the
United States to have confidential
diplomatic Communications and I hope he
gets at least 176 years in jail for what
he did it's a very strong words there
Gabriel
um and that is if you shared by a lot of
Americans there's no question
particularly in the political sphere on
the Republican side certainly who
believe that what your brother did
was bordering on treason what do you say
to that
well everything that Julian published it
was in the public interest and he
partnered with these media organizations
as John said so you're talking about all
the the largest Prestige media
organizations around the world who
published the exact same information uh
people uh like John Bolton they would
like to be able to classify everything
so that the public had no idea what that
what the governments that they elected
were getting up to and I think it's
particularly in the United States now
you're seeing a larger and larger
movement for government accountability
people understanding that a
classification of documents is is
totally uh overused you know Joe Biden's
has classified documents in the boot of
his Corvette Trump has classified
documents in the basement of Mar-A-Lago
this overclassification of documents so
that the public doesn't understand then
what the government is doing
is really a problem for democracy and
you have to ask ourselves
knowing about what our government does
in our name is is our right and our
Democratic right and do we want to live
in a democracy or do we want to live in
a tyranny where governments act with
impunity in secrecy uh and no
accountability accountability
accountability let me bring in will get
us now who's a security expert will be
spoken about this before but what is
your reaction to this because it is a
complex issue you know my my
journalistic side believes in free
speech I believe a lot of what Wikileaks
exposed was absolutely in the public
interest but I do think there are also
legitimate concerns about the sheer
amount of material that was put out
there which could well have put lives in
Jeopardy what do you think about it
well appears I'd agree with you entirely
I think uh there are some aspects of the
information that wasn't released by
acknowledge which was in the public
interest but public interest is a very
subjective word or term there is
information that does require
confidentiality I I work with
confidential information on a daily
basis and that information has to be
secured for a variety of a very wide
spectrum of reasons and one of the
greatest concerns is there was simply a
release of information that was not
filtered necessarily I believe in the
public interest and when we talk about a
democracy and about there being access
to certain information that democracy
can be undermined by that information or
certain information being protected now
I do believe in whistleblowers and I do
believe that there is a reason and also
purpose for whistleblowing but there was
information that assault was responsible
for whether he had acquired it himself
or he was publishing it on behalf of
other parties is the problem is is as
the disseminator of that information he
was putting a lot of National Security
particularly in the United States at
Great risk and also other members of
obviously the intelligence community and
that was putting lives at risk that's
what we've got to bear in mind it wasn't
just uncovering atrocities or misuses of
power this was information that helps us
keep our country safe against the bad
guys the terrorists out there who want
to find out about how those instruments
of intelligence are used and what is
available to them
let me bring back in John Simpson John
in January President Biden was accused
of hypocrisy for demanding the release
of journalists detained around the world
while he continues seeking the
extradition of your son what did you
think of that
oh you know
if I could just address a few of the
items that were rattled off there as
though their the as though the the
utterings of Truth they're simply not
Robert E Gates the Secretary of Defense
and testimony to the the Congress the
state of categorically under eyes that
it was awkwardly embarrassing but no
damage was done General Carr giving
evidence at the trial of Chelsea Manning
stated equally categorically under oath
nobody was hurt so those assertions that
people make founded upon Conjuring up
Ghosts of Fear
the all of government
investigation in the Australian
government made the same similar
declaration no laws were broken so those
statements where people conjure up fears
that something may have happened
something may be happen in the future
and this and that was in danger as
simply baseless assertions
rather loudly denying the fact that
there are crimes involved in this and
they point to the fact that maybe
somebody's endangered when the 400
000 Iraq war files
revealed clearly
that fifteen thousand civilian deaths
had been gone unreported
and what is it with these people that
can't address the matter of what the
files actually reveal and deal with that
and then if the if they feel that
certain Secrets have been uh uh
uncomfortable then cause the United
States and supernet to look after their
own
secrets rather than blaming Julian and
Chelsea Manning these people can't
manage their own secrets
God's sake man
John you sound weary from this you sound
exhausted uh fighting this battlefield
Sun how do you think this ends
oh you know you just uh appears uh deal
with each day as it comes and try and
keep a bit calm it's in early morning
here so I never good in the mornings I I
after midday I Rouse up a bit but the
ending will be
the Yearning For Justice in people's
heart and the revulsion that Injustice
will prevail in this matter millions of
people around the world join us every
single Civil Society organization in the
United States of standing has written 27
of them have written to Biden asking for
the charges to be dropped sorry turmeric
Garland the the the the of the doj
Department of Justice asking for the the
five Great media Legacy newspapers that
partner in this distribution of these
Revelations the the New York Times the
guardian the el pay in Spain and Le Mans
under Spiegel in Germany
of equally written to the Department of
Justice head Mary Garland and asked for
the the charges to be dropped the
phenomenon and the problem is global and
the phenomenon and the problem is
addressed globally by people concerned
with this Injustice John and Gabriel
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me uh the passion is clear and
the battle goes on and we'll thank you
very much indeed for joining me as well
I appreciate it